saletta a bahia
[Applauso]
avete consigliato boy e cioè il nostro
cagnolino berlino contro a le moto di
crediti che silvia l'angolino quelli che
segnerà alex è la fine del video chi
avrà lo stand più bello e con i suoni
smr migliori vince mai media fino alla
fine per vedere tutte le scelte di
merlino contro quelli di a lei come vice
l'ex sapete perché perché merlino stanno
dormendo ha preferito di potete dormire
per mangiare poco farà superattivo
sgranocchiando qualsiasi cosa è diviso
in mamma mia poi dopo si è addormentato
all'improvviso abbiamo dovuto aspettare
che si svegliasse ma tu sei cresciuto
barbino diventate ingombranti possiamo
mettere più qui sopra è cresciuto
velocissimo vento e questo fattore
questo patatone non so di un van dyck se
volete vedere altre palle slime oltre
salenko berlino consigliate sicure nei
commenti altre sale se volete vedere poi
sbadigliando cosa prendete le cose tv
boxcar abbracciato il vostro cane o
gatto gravità le havre a berlino e io ho
alexa la reflex volete vedere anche il
contrario magari ne uscirà qualcosa di
completamente diverso
questo video è di 10 mila ex faremo
anche berlino contro siri sempre
totalmente interessato ad alessia che
stenta e chiedo a lei delle crocs che
sono perdenti
si sta già girando negli stadi la
vediamo inizia carta marisa berlino vuoi
presto questo ho chiesto come mai la
canzone di sfocatura nelson e protettore
dove stai
alexa a bahia
valenza abbaia i marlins amarezza tipo
ma non impossibile seguirono minimo ma
eccoli lì è iniziato ad abbaiare no
nanette allora merlino ha scelto di
dormire
all'inizio assente lorenzo ne ridicole
scegliamo l'arancione il primo che ha
toccato dobbiamo prendere con la regione
o blu vediamo questo ha giocato celeste
è stato fortunato perché capita quindi
evitare ai blu blu colori di giulio non
tocca mai chiedere ad alexa che color 6
paletta dimmi un colore a caso rosso di
per sé verde quindi razza contro gli
altri
vediamo come diventa il rosso che ha
scelto alexa vediamo un po come ci sta e
il famoso rosso perlato vediamo un po
come diventa però non avevamo ancora
provato nella colla bianca è bellissimo
è fortissimo questo colore io devo
mettere di meno perché superport e va
benissimo perché ora volta mischiato col
werder inter a ballare come dice che
vede capiterà il verde scusa e chiusure
di capitale il verde le pagliette
brillantini basta non emettiamo troppo
che fortunato e bellissimo questo che
tra l'altro il colore del mio team ma
oggi è bello è diventato bravo celestino
ha chiaro con il per bene chissà chi la
vincerà questa sfida merlino alex di
berlino che abbiamo la schiavo di pepa
pigs freghiamo
la lezione sento lì nero per le palline
multicolor e le palline
quindi per ora sotto bene ma poi
arriveranno anche ingredienti al essa
scegli un numero a caso tra 1 e 5 2
ho risposto alla tua domanda sì grazie
kelin tuo feedback ok profumato chissà
adesso berlino che cosa sceglierà se
quanto mai sceglierà le tue che sente
rumore
il franchi come le crocchette se il
testo in arresto resto questo li metto
tutti i vigili quali siti con i figli
[Musica]
michele scelta dalla collina conto tv ha
toccato pur primo questi conti sarebbero
state bene il mio slide rosse mese nel
tuo céleste rossa non si arresterà tutto
qua allora il mio rosso non so perché ma
sta diventando sta cambiando colore è
diventato rosa sì mi piace ancora di più
ovviamente mettiamo la lazio ne
diventerà bella procurato e ha detto
troppo per me sarà profumato oggi e
speriamo bene almeno ora il colore si
schiarisce con il bianco e diventa
ancora perrotta che propugna
non chiamo non si vaga per un provino
con le palline rosse che ha scelto
merlino che tra noi
secondo me sia il mondo è sì ci vediamo
adesso che mischiamo tutto se verranno
colorate dalle lo slime son estremo sarà
terzo attenzione abbiamo altri coloranti
ma i famosi coloranti liquidi ve li
ricordate sono un paio figlio sono d'ora
in poi ci sono tabù chiamo al mero
abbiamo il nero abbiamo il lime che è
una sorta di verde scuro è scaduto anche
il sifone anche questo è un verde
verdino chiaro scaduto anche quello e
poi rosa pochettino poche fino di
arancione lor chiese che una sorta di
bird esco vediamo un po che colore e
scegli me arriva al regista osservando
bene tutti vediamo accetti tutti
guarda come vuole giocare cominciamo già
contento della scelta
[Applauso]
berlino sono in parte possa il bird è
per te arriviamo verde lime verde lime
celestino chiaro che conoscerà di
rigetto
[Musica]
vediamo non vedo l'ora di vederla più
corriere
vediamo se l'expo stata la mia parte ho
stata la tua parte 5 co magari riesce il
nero alexa scegli un colore a caso per
la di siena terra richieda non abbiamo
nessun color marrone terra di siena
quindi richiediamo glielo paletta
scegli un colore a caso tempo dicendo
che siccome oggi non vuole collaborare
ma non mi strane cose tranne sempre però
di scegliere un numero al extra se di un
numero tra 1 e 5 2
così pure salvata di poco mi sono
salvata scelto la ranzani
tra poco ci sta pure bene roma non ho
che fortunato nato ti becchi il verde
scelto da berlino io da leggere a
pochissimo anche le normative del fuoco
perché questa rosa è così forte ha
aggiunto
il più utile doveva essere stato
fortunato andiamo a mischiarlo vediamo
un po anche se non penso che cambierà
molto tanto in tanto in tanto in tutto
non è cambiato fico secco che come si
vede qualche riflesso è che non so se si
vede in camera bellissima e speriamo che
niente non la conosci smalto smalto
unghia così come è accaduto scelto da
berlina media mentre per noi siamo un
poco poco era tanto tre gocce 44 dolce
era subito questo green certo non si sia
infortunato diventa verde a verde acqua
verde acqua guardate il verde acqua dai
non ci possiamo lamentare pensavo peggio
dai non è brutta non è tutto diverso
poi ci sono poi ci sono tutti che i
brillantini che si vedono qui poco
mongole sottofondo al celestini quindi
direi che provo per te acque con i
brillantini celesti è perfetto e le
palline nostro bellissimo vabbè dai
avete sorridiamo berlino e alexa
dovranno scegliere tra questi figurano
attiva che questo il destino
se non avete visto il video in cui
compro tutto quello che berlino tocca
alle coste di animali andate a vederlo
dopo questo video perché un presunto
scrive il sole non vediamo cosa sceglie
berline allora poi parole ma mi sa che
non gliene frega niente tanto perché
adesso
chi perde si perde si sa mai cosa che
fortuna ma ci sta benissimo a rispondere
che è compilato anche berlino è tornato
a giocare qui sottolinea agitatissimo
stato fortunato che se ti rivediamo le
tasse sono sempre 5 alexa se il numero a
caso tra 1 e 5 5 celeste si ripartirà il
numero quattro c'è
sarebbe cioè la luce non farlo giro
vediamo ha detto come se porta a porta a
caso la fame è uscito il rosa che è il
colore del tuo slide matri uscita
celeste che colore del mio che mettiamo
il nostro celeste che sento rex tanto
tanto un punto contro buche bel colore
però non penso che si amalgamerà
bene
mettiamo sta diventando sta diventando
viola forse che bello è diventato un
violetto chiaro più o meno bello mi
piace tantissimo siamo stati fortunati
in forza alle super il momento vediamo
come un cina che li vediamo un po come
diventa il tuo berlino invece super
attento a rosicchiarsi il suo
giocattolino è vero rho berlino che
vediamo un po come diventa questo
celeste rosso con questa rosa antico tra
l'altro gold vediamo un po finiamo per
noi si sta schierando marrone marrone
che sta diventato rosa sta diventando
grigio
berlino che grigio grigio rosa rosa
grigio con una rosa antico con le
sfumature grigie
bene bravo berlina
gli ingredienti sono andati parli così
potete votare con il migliore è stata
più brava lezza o berlino siete pronti
ecco quel news live bellissimo sembra 1
boruc bubblegum apporti che super lucido
vedete sembra fatto con la bolla
trasparente invece che quella bianca poi
il colore mi piace tantissimo
sembra un grossisti animo sentiamo fuori
adesso
[Musica]
tenterà quindi piazza diaz laimer mi
piace un sacco il colore
vediamo ora collegi vitale miu miu è un
rosa antico con riflessi celestini
scelto da bambino con le palline rosse
sempre via twitter no
e i glitter visto che bellino allora il
colore un po particolare non è super
acceso per l'utima nido però è molto
carina particolare poi le palline e gli
danno quell'aspetto birthday cake ma non
troppo
e niente rimane super allungabile è
superfluo afoso stesso per foto e un po
più afoso e niente sentiamo i suoni
adesso sono questi suoni e sogni sono
nascosti no ci sono suoni di gioco vi
non è proprio il massimo però info
cannes ci si sente questa francia ma
diciamo non lo attivato neanche troppo
attivazione purtroppo col bicarbonato e
non è bruciata è carino ha chiarito non
fatti di peggio vediamoli uno affianco
all'altro
una rosa per di burro sempre la rosa la
cantata come fine ma chi e morbide molto
morbido ambito show in pole voletta wow
è bravo un profumo di pane e non è vero
che sono venuto allora voto che qua nel
sondaggio ore anche intorno slide di
berlino è pronto ad un blues live fatto
toccare di alexa votate chi vince
considerate sicure nei commenti che
andrà challans volete che facciamo sia
slime non slide 24 ore con meno un
bambino consigliate istituto nei
commenti ora vi lascio qui a quattro
casi discoteca e cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione